the resident evil 7 biohazard opening
hour demo that's a mouthful
has had an update and everyone wants to
know what the finger is for
well the solution to that is slowly
incoming and here's everything we found
in the latest update
once you've found the lockpick in the
first video open the draw and go back to
the draw in the present day and grab the
hatchet
next activate the stairs by finding the
missing fuse in the cubby hole behind
where you start the game
going to the attic and lo and behold the
room which had a wall before
now has a massive hole instead this
leads to a new area
in here you will find a window that
doesn't open even when you try it 50
times
on the table there is a key which says
basement
just by the bed is a bullet you can pick
up and if you use your hatchet you can
smash open the boxes to the left and
grab a few more bullets
next there is an inscription on the wall
which reads five guests murdered
but where is unknown nothing to point to
their final gravestone
this may sound like utter gibberish but
i think this may have something to do
with a dummy finger from the previous
demo
the digit is in the draw by the foot of
the stairs just in case you haven't got
it already
but look there's more next to the old
tube tvs is the remnant of a hand
if you combine both that hand and the
dummy finger you now have a pointing
device
if we go back to the bloody inscription
five guests murdered but where is
unknown
nothing to point to their final
gravestone could this dummy hand be the
key
to point to these gravestones if you've
uncovered anything else like secrets or
theories or where the hell the handgun
is for all these bullets
please let us know below also if you
want to see me freaking out for the
first time i've played this demo
don't pull it your bell end click the
link on screen and it's also in the
description i'm adam from playstation
grenade and please help our tiny channel
grow by clicking subscribe
i'll see you next time